hello
my name is ozan and i'm a senior
researcher in microsoft research
cambridge
today together with my colleague anton
we are presenting our latest research
work
in project inri in particular we will
talk about
how we augment radiotherapy workflows
with deep learning models
to save clinicians time and empower them
the talk will be structured in two parts
in the first part
i will briefly describe the conventional
radiotherapy workflow
and how we augment it with our machine
learning models
followed by our research findings and in
the second part of the talk
antoine will introduce the inner eye
open source toolkit and explain
how to build the state-of-the-art deep
learning solutions using in-house data
sets
before i begin explaining these models i
would like to give you
a brief introduction of the role of
medical imaging
as you might know the future of medicine
lies in early diagnosis
and individual tailored treatments also
known as personalized medicine
it aims to deliver the right treatment
to the right patient
at the right time medical imaging has
always been personalized
and is fundamental to almost all aspects
of personalized medicine
when we look at the history of radiology
we have seen a significant progress over
the decades from digitalization
management of scans in hospitals to
clinical decision support systems
and in the future we will be able to
collect measurements
from scans in a more accurate manner and
integrate this information with multiple
sources
to achieve definitive diagnosis and more
focused treatment
and as project inner eye our vision is
to be part of this process
by democratizing such image analysis
systems to
empower healthcare providers for better
patient outcome
so let me give you an example of one of
our projects
radiotherapy is one of the research
areas where we have been focusing on
over the last few years
in cancer treatment as you might know
there are several ways of treating
patients
ranging from surgery chemotherapy to
immunotherapy
and intensive modulated radiation
therapy is one of them
it has become a key component of
contemporary cancer treatment
a linear accelerator also known as linac
is a device commonly used
to deliver the radiation treatments as
you can see on the left hand side
it focuses high intensity radiation to
destroy tumors
while avoiding surrounding healthy
organs and this requires an execution
plan
in order to maximize the radiation dose
over cancer's health
and minimize it on healthy tissues for
this reason it is essential to produce
personalized radiation treatment plants
that match patients you need under
chemical configuration
and if you look at the standard clinical
workflow for radiotherapy
workflows we see that couple of steps
and in the first step patients first of
all undergo tomographic scans
and later radiation oncologists manually
annotate these scans to identify target
tumors
and the surrounding healthy organs which
are later used to create a dose plan to
guide the treatment
and the treatment is delivered in
multiple fractions with lower dose
amount
but the same plan is used over time
and the planning procedure requires
manual donation of tumor tissues
and the surrounding target organs in
these 3d volumetric images
as you might expect this can take up
anywhere from 30 minutes to
hours as there are often tons of exhale
slices and a few target organs to be
annotated
in addition to that there is a clear
demand in standardizing the quality of
this procedure across hospitals in
particular in clinical trials
and here on the left hand side you're
seeing 3d donations
generated on prostate and head and neck
ct scans
so in our research we explored how
machine learning could fit in this
process
and augment it in a clinically useful
way
this way of approach towards
healthcare-related problems
differentiates us from other machine
learning labs
in our approach we aim to automate the
contouring process i just mentioned
in order to save clinicians time while
skipping them in the loop in case manual
intervention is required
in more detail our deep learning models
provide an accurate initial set of
counters the declination must review
and most of the time they do not need
any adjustments or very minor ones
and additionally this can allow more
adaptive forms of radiotherapy
where plans are updated across visits or
fractions
thanks to the reduced time demand in the
next slides
i would like to walk you through our
methodology and our validation
strategies
on showing how effective these models
are and how they can actually reduce the
planning time
first of all i elected mention that we
have recently published our research
work
in a clinical journal germa network open
in this research we basically tried to
evaluate the
clinical utility of deep learning models
in two particular radiotherapy domains
namely hedonic and prostate cancers
and this research work mainly try to
find an answer to the following question
can machine learning models achieve
clinically acceptable accuracy in image
segmentation tasks
in radiotherapy planning and reduce the
overall contouring time
as you can see we are not just
interested in model accuracy obtained on
a holdout test set
but we are interested in how could these
models actually help radiation
oncologists in their daily routine
and this always requires clinically
acceptable accuracy
and incorporation of these models into
frameworks in a minimally disruptive way
while ensuring clinical safety besides
this research question
we have also focused on other aspects
in particular how well these metals
generalize on external data sets
and different cancer types and how these
models could be actually integrated in
clinical workflows and what will be the
interactions required
these are the aspects in addition to the
reduction annotation time
and to to give further information about
this we followed the concert ai
guidelines which were recently published
and dedicated to randomized clinical
trials
our work is more classified as process
improvement but we believe that some of
these guidelines can be useful for
studies
that involve machine learning or ai in
their workflow
so to begin with i would like to present
our
proposed clinical workflow in a research
setting
the boxes shown on the white and uh the
white boxes showed on the left-hand side
illustrate the conventional workflow and
on the right hand side we're
illustrating
the model training and inference
performed in azure cloud
the presented workflow enables
oncologists to use their existing
clinical systems for review and editing
the contours as you can see
once the images are processed and the
contours are available
which makes this technology more
accessible across clinics
is the existing workflows are maintained
and in return the required countries
will be available for planning
in the order of minutes rather than ours
and lastly it is important to note that
this is not a clinical product but a
research study in machine learning and
health care
domains to check the feasibility and
potential benefits of ai
in radiotherapy planning
and the data sets are that we use in
this study are also very important
and i would like to briefly explain what
kind of data we have used in this study
as you might know one of the barriers to
the uptake of machine learning in
clinical use
across different hospitals is that most
of these models are only trained on a
data set from a single institution
or focus on a single task to overcome
this problem
we use anonymized data sets from eight
different clinical centers
across the globe all identifying
information was removed from the data
by the clinical sites prior to the
transfer to microsoft research
and training and validation on
multi-site is an important aspect
as the lack of generalization can reduce
the potential utility of machine
learning
in real world applications such as due
to
different image acquisition settings or
patient
cohort groups to give further details on
the data sets
the proposed models were trained on an
anonymized set of
519 pelvis and 242
hedonic 3d ct scans and more importantly
these images were categorized into two
different buckets
per radiotherapy domain as main sites
and the external sites
the images uh put in the external sites
were not used at training and validation
of the models to be able to test the
model's
generalization ability on previously
unseen data sets
in a in a way we have performed a blind
evaluation
and these scans were mainly encountered
by an expert reader
and three senior radiation oncologists
and in particular we were interested in
15 different structures
and we were trying to produce
segmentations for those structures
let me walk you through what kind of
methodology we have used to generate
these autocounters
the image segmentation model is a
state-of-the-art convolutional neural
network
as you can see with the meetings of
learn parameters at training time
and the design is similar to a 3d unit
architecture
with some modifications to better
utilize the computation hardware
and increase the number of samples used
in model parameter updates in stochastic
gradient
design this includes mixed precision
representations
memory efficient tensor aggregation
blocks and model partition
across multiple hardware and we use
microsoft azure machine learning
to develop and train these models across
20 nvidia tester cards
i would like to get into more details on
how we actually partition these models
because this technique allows us to
process full 3d volume scans
and it eliminates the need for image
patch-based processing of scans
which is a commonly used approach but it
can lead to redundant computations and
inferior performance at test time
by using this modal partitioning large
contextual information
and bad statistics are collected for
each parameter update
and contextual information usually
matters in medical imaging domain
where tissue contrast is low and prior
knowledge is required
such as in head and neck scans and how
did we perform this task
to begin with we first looked at the
memory fingerprint of each layer
and after identifying the memory need of
each layer we try to
distribute these layers across multiple
hardware in a balanced manner
while ensuring the continuity of
operations within the computation graph
now i would like to show you how these
models perform in a qualitative sense
before we discuss about the metrics and
the quantitative measurements
so here we are seeing the results
obtained on three different subjects
coming from main and external data sets
and the auto segmentations were
generated for six different structures
on these pelvic ct scans and
what we commonly see is that on the
external data sets
the scans might sometimes have larger
true plane resolution and this can
actually be a challenging situation for
the models
but more importantly when we look at the
head and neck scans
on the external data sets we have
actually
worked with update images containing
imaging artifacts
and lower tissue contrasts and this was
mainly associated with beam hardening
and metal artifacts
and training models on a direct set of
data sets as performed in this study
is an effective way to cope with this
kind of challenges
and it is also important to note that
the annotation protocol differences
across sites is an important aspect and
we had to review the data sets and their
labels
to make to ensure the consistency
between them
so in the remaining slides i would like
to present you
the quantitative metrics that we used to
validate these models
and how the models so to begin with
um we should talk about the metrics that
we use
just to understand how in terms of the
accuracy how about these models perform
and then later on i will talk about the
clinical utility
aspects and uh here we are seeing two
commonly used metrics in the literature
here on the left-hand side
we're seeing the volumetric agreement
measurements obtained with dice core
and on the right-hand side we are saying
the surface-to-surface distance metrics
commonly used to understand how gross
the mistakes produced by the models are
volumetric measurements usually range
between zero to hundred percent
agreement
where hundred percent agreement
corresponds that two volumetric counters
basically have a full agreement
but i would like to note that these
metrics do not necessarily directly
translate into time savings
however it's a minimal requirement for
clinical acceptability
and measuring inter-observer variability
and additionally there's a minimal
requirement bar that we will
we need to meet so that clinicians
actually consider using these auto
segmentations as a starting point
instead of doing it from scratch
so here in this part in this box plot
we are seeing the results obtained using
this dice metric
on six different structures on pelvis
scans
and this course these dice scores were
completed on
test images coming from both external
and internal data sets
and the reason why we performed this
experiment was that we wanted to see
if the model performance drops because
of
the generalization issues and ideally we
would like the model to perform
consistently well on both internal and
external sites
and to analyze these results further we
perform statistical testing to
check if there is any statistical
difference between these sets of images
or the performances and what we observed
is that basically
our models consistently perform well in
both external and internal uh data sets
it's also important to note that these
models can always be fine-tuned
on on-premises data sets if it's
required for example data sheets
data shifts could be severe due to
acquisition protocols
and fine tuning can always be used as a
backup option
and more importantly i think we should
also look at the clinical utility aspect
namely time savings and this experiment
is a more human-centric approach to
evaluate the performance of a machine
learning model
and this is one of the main
differentiating points of our
research work here we're showing the
potential time savings and this could
actually translate into clinicians
having more time to spend with their
patients for
person-to-person interactions let me
explain
in more detail what we did in here the
blue bar represents the time taken to
perform
image segmentation tasks manually by an
expert radiation oncologist
on 10 hedonic ct scans with varying
imaging quality
and the bottom bar shows the model's
runtime plus the time for the same
expert
to review and update the contours while
ensuring the clinical accuracy
and we observe similar gains on the
prostate scans
and time taken was less due to fever
number of structures to be annotated
and in these experiments an in-house
image annotation software
was used both for contouring and
correction tasks
which includes assistive contouring and
interactive comfort
refinement tools and we expect that
these gains can be further extended as
we start including
more target structures in the planning
stage
reduced planning time is an important
utility of these models as you can see
however
this should be complemented by
clinically acceptable contours
generated by these models as well and in
order to assess this we run a separate
experiment
together with multiple clinical experts
and measured
the inter-expert availability in this
contouring task on a subset of images
so let me begin with how we collected
the annotations
a subset of images from both
radiotherapy domains were annotated by a
set of experts
as you can see on the left hand side
multiple times
and the gold standard contours were
extracted by aggregating their candidate
annotations
and afterwards we assess the variability
observed across these
experts to understand the bounds of
clinical acceptability
and perform the statistical agreement
analysis between the contours generated
by these
by these experts and the models
so let's have a look at how they look
like in a qualitative manner
here we're showing the prostate contours
collected from the model
and the experts on obtained on two
different
uh pelvis scans the color map shows the
surface distance errors with respect to
the gold standard contours i just
mentioned
and the red color represents the surface
points
with distance error larger than 2.8
millimeter
so the main thing that we should focus
on here are these uh contour errors
and these contour areas are mainly
concentrated at the surface points
adjacent to the bladder and the rectum
mainly at the interface of the organs
and the modal contours are
aligned with the ones originating from
the first experts so our model basically
does not perform
arbitrary segmentations and their errors
are correlated with the
experts errors and if you look at the
results from a quantitative perspective
what we did is we looked at the dice
scores
and the the variability across experts
and how the model performance fits uh
within that distribution
and we see that there's statistical
agreement between these
two sets of measurements and for this we
performed flight cap analysis and
generated blunt outbound plots
for further details please check the
supplementary material of our research
paper
and when we look at the results obtained
on the head and neck scans
we also saw statistical agreement
between the
struct between the experts and the model
except for submandibular glands
and the reason why we observed this
difference is mainly associated with
low tissue contrast and the absence of
the organ
due to previous resection surgery
in short out of 15 structures
we have observed clinically acceptable
performance
on 13 of these structures that we have
used in this study
and lastly i would like to give you a
short summary of uh part of the
statistical argument analysis we did and
here we are seeing the blonde outbound
plots
uh obtained for two different structures
namely prostate and rectum
and the purpose of these plots basically
is to understand
how well the model performance agrees
with experts and we would like to
analyze this on a sample basis and here
each point is representing the image or
the patient
data that we have used in the study and
if the models and the expert performance
agrees
we will ideally expect this to be fall
between the confidence intervals and
this is what we have observed for the
structures that we used
additionally we have recently released a
blog post
describing the findings of our research
paper and also the
open source toolkit that we have
recently released
so if you would like to check out this
blog post please follow this web link
at the bottom
next my colleague anton will introduce
in our deep learning toolkit
it is an open source library and he will
talk about how to build these
state-of-the-art
medical image segmentation models in
azure in a scalable
and efficient manner using in-house
imaging data sets
i would like to thank you for your
attention so let me transfer to anton
thanks very much rosanne my name is
anthon i'm a principal software engineer
in the in writing so ozan has just
presented
a set of really amazing research results
but i think what
matters most here at these these are
research results that not only look
great on paper but they have been
validated
in a clinical context so we know
that using such ai models in a clinical
workflow
can really make a tremendous difference
to what is otherwise
a really mundane time-consuming tedious
task for clinicians
these days researchers are not only
asked about
the great results that they produced but
they are also asked
how did you achieve them is what you're
telling us really
reproducible and these questions are
asked
in particular also to research results
that come out of big tech organizations
so we've tackled these questions head on
by just putting all of the codes that we
have been using in this research project
out on github so that includes
all of the model architectures all of
the tweaks
all of the boring bits if you will
now there was probably a second now even
bigger goal
that we wanted to achieve with open
sourcing our
our code
now building these clinical grade
segmentation models
really requires a lot of expertise at
different levels
at an infrastructure level at the
machine learning level
and we wanted to make this process a lot
easier for
organizations in particular where
technology is not the main focus we're
thinking in particular of
hospitals here so hospitals usually have
tons of data they have burning problems
where maybe a well-built ai model
could make a tremendous difference but
they do not have the time
or the expertise to really invest in
getting started on machine learning
model building from scratch
and by open sourcing our toolbox we
wanted to
enable those organizations to do as well
as we did
now one important feature of our in
right toolbox is really that it tries to
make
best use of cloud computing and i feel
that cloud computing is really a big
enabler here in particular for
organizations where technology is not
the main focus
because it just dramatically lowers the
entry barrier
to doing deep learning at a reasonable
scale
so what the cloud enables us and
other organizations as well is that
there is only
no longer a need for making a humongous
upfront investment
in an expensive tpu cluster we can get
everything out of the cloud
and in particular set it out in such a
way that it scales precisely to
the workload that we have today and most
importantly this also means
if we're not building ai models today
we're not going to pay for it
but apart from the infrastructure level
using cloud computing for building ai
models also makes a tremendous
difference to how
a team can operate and we've certainly
experienced that
in our own in the inri team so
our previous workflow was pretty much
that everybody was working on their
individual
tpu machines and all of our model
building results were sitting on these
individual machines effectively siloed
from the rest of the team
now when we're switching everything to
cloud first
it means that all of our modeling
results are stored inside of an
azure machine learning workspace and now
this gives us a completely new level of
transparency i can now just take
any of my colleagues results dig in
compare with
what i have achieved and so we are
really able to push forward as a team in
a completely new fashion
it also gives us a lot of traceability
and reproducibility
if for example at some later point we
wish to
implement something like a quality
management system
and the cloud is also great when it now
comes to putting these models
just out of their pure training context
and
if we wanted to for example spin a spin
up a small web service
and use these models outside
in a real world workflow for example
now let's talk a little bit more about
what the inri toolbox brings
on top of these general cloud computing
benefits
the inride toolbox contains all of the
model architectures that we've used in
order to achieve
the results that osan has just presented
and that have been published in our
channel paper
there's a ton of reporting and
diagnostics built in
you have capabilities like model
comparison
so that we would know for example if we
build a new prostate segmentation model
how does that stack up against the best
prostate segmentation model that our
team has built so far
so all in all it means that you would
have to write
a lot less of mundane boring boilerplate
code
but while everything comes with a cloud
focus we absolutely
recognize that it is important for model
diagnostic and development purposes
to be able to also run on individual gpu
boxes
so this is why we focused on building a
seamless transition so you can start out
on your local box with your model
development and switch
to using the cloud with just one single
additional
command line argument
i wanted to briefly mention also the
technology stack that we are using here
so on the infrastructure level we are
using azure machine learning
for the machine learning bits this is
all based on
pi torch and pi torch lightning
the latter for doing all of the
distributed training for example
and on top of that sits the in right
deep learning toolkit
and with this toolbox you can now build
segmentation models
classification and regression models and
also
sequence models and most of those models
can be
built with a combination of non-image
and image features
let's also talk for a moment about the
machine learning
life cycle because i'm going to present
some steps of that
and how they relate to the inroad
toolbox in a minute
so we would start out here with
data in daikon nifty format so daikon
of course being the predominant format
for medical images
with data suitably prepared you would
now in the machine
in the inri toolbox you would write a
model configuration
that's a piece of python code you would
run that through the inri trainer you
would get a performance report
you would inspect that and based on the
performance that your model currently
achieves
you would now tweak the model
configuration change for example the
capacity of your model
change crop sizes something like that
however it is also important that in
particular in a medical domain
we should not treat the data as a given
so
the performance report really also
highlights
cases that hint at the data
being in somewhat inconsistent or
incorrect
so when you analyze the performance
report
it may actually mean that you have to go
back to the data
in the road icon format and for example
ask an expert to review specific
segmentations
and correct them
once you're done with your with your
model building
then you would have the option to deploy
it
in some form of validation environment
and eventually you would also want to
monitor any model
that is deployed in production so this
is
all very general and applies to all
machine learning models
now how do these steps look like
specifically for the inri toolbox
so we would start out with data
so data for model training
is
organized here by folders so you would
have a folder for each patient so
here in this example this is patient
zero patient one patient two
this is an example from a public
lung segmentation challenge data set
that we're also using in the model
documentation
for each fold in each folder you would
have a ct scan
for the patient and you would have
binary masks
so these binary masks have the same size
as the
ct scan and each pixel here in this
binary mask
means is the corresponding
pixel in your ct scan is part of the
heart yes or no
is that part of the left lung yes or no
and we would have that for all of our
patients
you would then take this file structure
and cook it into a very simple
data dataset.csv format
and here in the last column we have what
we call channels
and we're going to refer to these file
paths or channels
when we now build the
model configurations in the next step
so this is an example of how a model
configuration for this lung segmentation
challenge
would look like you would write a
piece of python code a new class called
lung
that derives from the base class for
segmentation models
and there are essentially only three
things that you need to specify
you would have to specify a channel name
for
the points to the files that contain
your input ct scan
and you would have to specify the three
anatom
the five anatomical structures that we
want to segment
the last piece of information is pretty
much a folder name
where in azure does this data set
actually live
or where only a local box does it live
the rest is something that's already in
the in the fine tuning range
so many of these settings are already
pre-populated in the base class
so if you want to want to tweak for
example the number of feature channels
in your unit
this is how you would specify that you
just pass an additional argument here
into the class constructor
now with these things in place the data
set
and the model configuration you're
already
set for running the
the in right training code so you would
create a python environment and activate
it
and then start the inri runner and
specify
the name of the model that you want to
train as a command line argument
and then it would go ahead and start
training on your local box
if you have a gpu in your local box it
would use that otherwise the cpu
now if we wanted to do exactly the same
thing running in
the cloud in azure machine learning then
you would just specify an additional
switch
azure ml equals true and what that
would what that does now is effectively
take a snapshot of the code that leaves
on your local folder
sends it over it sends it over to the
cloud it allocates a virtual machine in
your gpu cluster
and starts the training there so this
whole process takes about
20 to 30 seconds and then you're done
once the job is queued in the cloud
you can now go over to the azure machine
learning workspace
and inspect your current runs this is
how
how that looks like so let's inspect the
most recent
run here so we have all of the
information there
about which command line arguments did
we actually give this training run we
have information which git commit was
used
upon submission there is a set of
editable tags
that you can use to attach additional
metadata
and you can pretty much watch the
training by just inspecting what the
lace the latest console
out of your job was there's graphing
functionality built in
you can pick a couple of dice scores for
example for different structures
and monitor how they evolve as training
progresses
in the snapshot tab you get the complete
record of
the code that was used for this specific
training run so if you want to for
example validate whether a specific
tweak
that you've played with is really
switched on or present in the code for
this run
this is how to do that
but now that we have all of our results
in a nice table form in the cloud
we can also very simply create a
dashboard
so this quick screen grab shows how to
do that
we can now for example specify that we
want to show the validation set loss
in our table and also pick the
validation set dice call for the left
lung lobe
let's add that to our columns as well
off we go
and we have a very simple dashboard
and do the same thing for graphs if we
want to see how
for example training progresses and
converges
for the most recent set of runs that
we've selected
now let's pick again here the validation
set dice call for the left lung lobe
and off we go
so we've tried to make best use of all
of azurmel's built-in reporting
capability
but there is also something very
specific to segmentation models that
we've
added here so in each
in each training run each train run of a
segmentation model
writes a html file that is effectively a
jupyter notebook
and this has all of the rather
specialized reporting here we would get
an overview table of dice core for the
different
structures that our model is predicting
get some some key graphs and we're
repeating the whole thing
for typical segmentation metrics
the dyscor um the house of distance
and the mean the mean surface distance
what is also contained in this report
here is a set of
structures rather a set of patients for
which the model performs particularly
poorly
so you can now go back and inspect for
example the ground truth
for some of the for some of the patients
it could also happen that you
realize that your model has hit the
capacity bounds
of your gpu so if you want to
now start training on a larger gpu this
shows how easy it is
to actually start up a completely new
gpu cluster
you just pick the type of gpu that you
want
say okay i want my cluster to have at
most
11 nodes and off we go
and within less than a minute we now
have a new gpu cluster to run our
training on
there are other a couple of other
capabilities that we should
maybe add here so you can turn on in the
model
configuration to also run cross
validation and hyper parameter tuning
both of those would make best use of the
cloud
in terms of scheduling just parallel
training runs
so doing five-fold cross-validation no
longer means that you have to wait five
times longer but everything is run in
parallel
so it saves you just a ton of time
and you can also build on sample models
similar to what we've done
in the channel paper and again this is
happening
in parallel
now how does this all fit into a bigger
picture
so if you want to evaluate
some of these research models in a
hospital setting
this is how such a clinical workflow
could look like
so you could hook up the model with
the with the hospital pack system
you would send it over to a gateway
system
so each pelvic ct scan for example
could now by the gateway sent to
a pelvic to a prostate segmentation
model
that is running here in the in in
inference service
and this model again comes out of the
azure machine learning training
and once the the model has been
has been finished it would send back a
segmentation that again goes back into
the pac system
and doctors can now inspect
correct approve and do something else
with this model with the segmentation
and we are at the moment working to put
those
additional pieces in place to make it
easier for everyone
to evaluate such kind of models in a
typical hospital setup like
like i'm showing showing here and this
should work both
in the cloud but also on-premise
so if your compliance model for example
requires the data does not leave the
hospital
trust boundaries there should be a way
for you to do that
so all of this work is of course only
possible with the help
of a lot of people some of whom are
listed up here
everyone here has contributed to
different aspects of this work
on the machine learning side on the
technology side
on helping us better understand all of
the clinical
requirements and i would also like to
call out all of the great support that
we got from the azure machine learning
team
if you would like to get in touch with
us please visit us on these web
locations
and with that i'm gonna end
thank you very much for your attention
and i'm looking forward to your
questions
hi everyone thank you for joining us
today my name is ozan
and together with my colleague anton we
will now have a live q a session
over the next 15 minutes we're going to
be answering questions from the audience
in particular the ones related to the
segmentation models and inner eye deep
learning toolkits
if you have any questions that you would
like to ask you can use the q a window
to submit them during this live session
maybe we can get started anton
our first question is from the audience
can you run inference on the cpu
uh can you leverage azure stack to run
inference on premises
instead of in the cloud
yeah thanks susan
given the size of these models it is not
really feasible to run inference on the
cpu
however we are working on
a full integration with with our azure
stack hub
so that you can indeed run inference
on-premise
instead of the cloud so this should
enable
um like district in particular for
people who have a very stringent privacy
model where data cannot leave for
example the hospital boundaries
i hope that answers the question also
let me
fire back with a question to you
um we have here a question
um in the future are you planning to
expand your studies
to include other modalities such as
x-rays and other diagnostics such as
pneumonia oh thank you anta
this is a very interesting question um
we have been considering
examining the the toolbox for other
modalities as well
and so within within each modality there
are obviously application specific
challenges uh in particular if you talk
about mri
uh modality uh for uh radiotherapy
planning for example
uh there will be challenges in terms of
tissue contrast
image resolution and we basically need
to take these
variations in the input space into
accounts when we train our models and
do the training but the proposed
underlying
technology is a generic and it's not
application specific
in that regard we do not see any um
big challenges uh for examining it to
other modalities
we hope that this answers the question
and then maybe i can pick one from the
list uh until
there is an interesting question for you
um it is great to hear about the
reproducibility of the results
can you summarize how do you ensure you
are able to do that
um thanks yeah so this is um
handled at two levels firstly we need to
make sure that
all sources of randomness in the in the
code itself
are carefully controlled for so this
means
things like random seeds obviously but
also multi-threading
the high torch backhand also has some
potential sources of non-determinism
here
but i think the more the more important
thing is to also treat
data sets as immutable so we need to
really make sure that
um a data set has a unique id and unique
structure
so that you if we're running the same
model um on the same data set
a year down the line we should we must
get the same results
so we have back-end infrastructure to
handle for
um to cater for this data set
immutability
however this is at present not part of
the toolbox
great thank you okay um
um should i just uh pick one for you
here
um
there's a question about the time saving
of anatomical segmentation
the impact on the total time to deliver
to do a high quality dose plan for
radiotherapy
okay this is this is also interesting so
um in our in our study what we looked at
is basically
um we looked at the the time
required for experts to make corrections
uh on these uh auto generated
segmentations to ensure a
similar quality those plans
so in that regard uh when we did this
time saving analysis
we didn't try to compromise from the the
quality of the plants
and uh this experiment was uh conducted
together with a radiation oncologist
um so the main purpose was basically
while ensuring the high quality
can actually reduce the time so in that
regard this was our
core priority
and maybe i can pick another question
from the list
um until uh this is an interesting one
again
uh and related to the previous ones uh
how many gpus are needed to
infer the models generally one does not
want to use 20 gpus as in training
uh not necessarily wants to use the gpu
on the cloud for inference did you try
to reduce the memory demands
so the first part of the question how
many gpus are needed for inference
we are using a single node with four
rather spacious gpus
um and we were using
model so partitioning the model across
multiple gpus
so that we can really feed in um like
large crops
and reduce all sorts of otherwise
like stitching artifacts
we were trying to be as careful with
memory demand as possible
however in particular patch size
has a huge impact on model accuracy
and we really wanted to push the model
accuracy to the maximum possible
with our given hardware so the models
are
in the end on the memory demanding side
okay i hope that answers the question
was on a question for you here
have you considered interaction loops
instead of doing an initial segmentation
with a single correction
phase can you say something about that
yes it's a very interesting point um so
in our in our experiments we haven't
considered this
um obviously such
active segmentation approach uh
will be definitely interesting to uh
explore in the research
setup that that basically requires a
data set where we uh collect uh with
experts like and they understand their
corrections
uh for each possible segmentation that
we produce
and that will involve more human and
computer interaction
but yeah we haven't explored this in
this study
i can maybe ask one more question anton
from that list i'm going through is it
possible to see the code
for 3d unit on your github or are they
only available through the azure ml
platform
yeah all of the code that was used
to produce this this paper is on github
and that includes also the
model architecture with all of its
details
so including model parallel so the
splitting of the model across multiple
gpus for
for inference this is all rightly
available
in the in the github repository
okay um awesome let me pick another
question for you here
um there's
one here um
in your presentation you highlight the
different training different parts of
the
3d v-net on multiple gpus we've tried
similar approaches
um could he comment on the trade-offs of
such an approach how would it compare
with deeper
2d networks and making inferences per
slice
very good question um so maybe we can
talk about why we use uh multiple gpus
uh first of all
uh what we have observed is that um
to to achieve high quality auto
generated counters uh
uh we need to teach these models out um
and make sure that they understand the
anatomical context
and that will require obviously that
that we provide
large input patches or volumetric
patches
to these models and uh in return the the
limitations basically the gpu memory so
uh to address that challenge we have
been basically utilizing multiple gpus
uh and that
gave us uh a big advantage
uh so in that regard uh if we try to use
a deeper 2d network uh
we will probably run into the problem of
uh limited contacts that we need to
understand
the 3d view uh to be able to um generate
a good quality so
this was the main reason why we opted
for this design our choice
and maybe i can pick one last question
um let me just add a post a quick post
scriptum to this question
we had another question in the same
direction is this true 3d
training or is it training on 2d images
so from what you just said um yes it is
true 3d training
that's correct thank you anton
um anton um i have a question um
from the list um do you uh what do you
see as the potential exception of this
framework for a future wider adoption of
this technology for
to be used in reddit therapy planning
what do you
see as the challenges
um for wide adoption
we need to make sure that
once the models are trained
we have easy ways of deploying them into
a clinical environment so where people
can then further evaluate
these models specifically for their
[Music]
for the types of scans that are taken in
that specific hospital
so simplifying deployment
and simplifying evaluation in a in a
clinical context
and also making sure that the toolbox
supports all of the
things that are needed for for example
quality management systems for like
whatever
whatever whatever clinical approvals
that such a model needs to go through in
the specific hospital where um
where people are looking into those
so uh okay so so it's
around yes deployment plus making sure
that um
it can be quality approved and uh
easily
thank you maybe i can add a few more
details on from machine learning
perspective to this question
so um we will need to um consider the
robustness of these models
to different patient groups and
variations that we observe in imaging
data
in our research study uh and in the
publication we have
done our best effort to test these
aspects of these models
across different uh population groups
and hospital setups
but i think uh for future uh wider
adoption uh we need to make sure that uh
these models are tested and
produce robust um uh outcomes
uh regardless of like uh the variations
obviously so it will definitely require
a further
evolution
um we hope that this answers the
question anton do you have any more
questions
from the audience regarding the paper
yes absolutely
there's one here how do different
devices affect the accuracy or
precision of the machine learning model
results
yes this is a very interesting question
uh and it's also related to
um to the previous one that we answered
in the in the data sets that we have
used we have
utilized datasets coming from different
scanner vendors and for further details
we suggest the audience to take a look
at the paper
the main differences we observed were
related to voxel resolution
uh in these images and also the contrast
changes and um regardless of the
scanner type we also saw variations
because of the population
population group so uh we did our best
effort to
uh try to take these uh such variations
into account to be able to build our
robust models and
uh we did an external validation to see
how well these models which is
generalized to
such particular differences yeah we hope
that this answers your question
maybe i can tack on one more that goes
in that direction
did you encounter any sampling bias and
how did you overcome it
we we haven't um we haven't the
noticed such kind of bias i mean
obviously some some domains uh for
example
uh prostate uh imaging uh involves uh
scans from uh male patients um what we
have been basically looking lately is
like uh
how these actually models are performed
on uh scans uh uh acquired from
female subjects for example uh we need
to make sure that uh these um
uh images actually pro the models
actually produce a reasonable contours
and um
and and these are the kind of like a
robustness aspects that we have been
looking into
and regarding other type of uh
variations
uh we try to cover like a resolution
contrast changing
uh or imaging artifacts uh but there
could be always like a
variation that we may not have uh
considered so far so uh
it's still an active area of research
and we're improving our models every day
thank you son
um anton uh i'm not able to see more uh
questions related to the toolbox uh if
you see any uh please
feel free to pick and um answer please
okay um do you want to pick one
um from the what we have in the inbox
now
yes i think i think rigby we can do that
um
there's a question on what was the gpu
model and memory capacity you used um
this is a new question maybe you can
answer
yeah um we were
using nvidia gpus with
24 gigabytes of memory
per node for the training and also for
the
for the inference
first do we have here um
there's one on better rated learning
here um because i'm sure
should we take that one yeah so
if you could ask the question um okay
that i can provide
are you using federated learning
algorithm and okay it's actually two
questions in one
so are you using federated learning and
all and the second question is
did you build your model based on the
unit architecture
second one um i can say if you answer
yes it's a unit but federated learning
yes very good question uh no we are not
using a federated learning it's a
it's an earlier research area that we're
closely
exploring and uh keeping ourselves up to
date but the models are not trained
using federated learning there is one
thing that uh to note i think is
important
when we train our models we make sure
that our data sets are clean and
they complement each other and data
quality is very
important for developing reliable and
robust
machine learning models so this has been
the the particular focus and
um but in the future we might actually
consider such uh research
areas
okay um maybe we can take one last
question on
and um yes
okay um um
there's one question here would
um gosh um would he be able to
implement attention based in the um
and attention based on the cnn
architecture
that's the question it's an interesting
question
it's an area in which i have done
research in the past
um yes it is possible uh to implement um
a fashion unit within the unit um
please take a have a look at our
github repository open source toolkit
it can be incorporated into the unit
architecture
and but in our applications we haven't
considered
um yet
[Music]
thanks very much okay
we're um at the end of our allocated
time thank you all very much for
attending today we appreciate your
participation and interest in particular
um if you're interested in learning more
there are a couple of resources listed
on the resource list that you should see
within the webinar
on the right side of your screen so this
includes lists to our
team home page and to the to the blog
post and the paper that we
that we presented today
and yes this is um open source
um so our results are out in the open
and we will look forward to seeing how
you build on top of this work
and hopefully together evolve healthcare
in a great new direction thanks very
much
everyone and have a great day